uh this time we're going to stay in the
same galaxy of cancer systems but a
totally different solar system as it
were we'll also touch on machine
learning statistics and large-scale data
our passionate speaker is dr kashturi
kanan an associate professor and
director of computational pathology
program at the university of texas md
anderson cancer center in houston texas
he's a data science with expertise
scientist with an expertise in cancer
economics epigenomics biomedical
informatics and image processing kashuri
is also working currently on systems
biology and spatial stachotic processes
with its application to multiplexed
immune
immunofluorescent images i'm not even
sure what i just said but i'm sure it'll
all be clear in the next 30 minutes or
so
sorry this this stage is yours thank you
sir for being here
oh thank you uh this has been a
wonderful gathering and it's my pleasure
i have known elia for quite some time
and i'm uh nice to meet him and
everybody here
so i uh let me start sharing my screen
you able to see my screen
we can see your screen but you might
want to go there you go absolutely great
all right
okay so let's get started without any
further ado today i'm going to talk
about bioinformatics and
cancer systems biology in particular i'm
going to touch upon why bioinformatics
has been
critical for cancers cancer systems
biology
um i have nothing to disclose or no
conflict of interest
before going into the topic uh first of
all i would like to establish my
credentials on uh
on this area in general about uh you
know
what what led me so far uh the current
position here basically i'm a
mathematician i got my masters
in mathematics uh from india and then i
moved on here to study mathematics in
particular i was more interested in
topology approximation theory etcetera
etcetera
but my interest shifted towards computer
science and i graduated with a
with a phd in computer science
especially in computational physics
until about 2008 i have no idea of what
bioinformatics is
or biology in biology or bioinformatics
i should share an anecdote that in fact
my mentor she wanted me to pursue
bioinformatics and she was interested in
protein folding and at that point i said
no no i'm not at all interested in
bioinformatics
but
it later turned out that i went to a
medical research institute where i got
some basics of biology and that led me
um
naturally to bioinformatics
you know working with the data sets
biological data sets
and i was doing genomics uh large scale
systems studying brain tumors at
memorial sloan kettering cancer center
and then that led me to the position at
new york university where i was an
assistant professor and
i came to know about elia and we had a
good conversation and i got introduced
to him at that point
and slowly that led me to our current
position at md anderson cancer center i
am an associate professor and director
uh driving majorly uh what is known as
computational pathology and but that's
not going to be the topic of today i'm
going to talk about uh one of the
another uh exciting area that i've been
um that have been working for about uh
maybe two years now uh in general my
expertise are
i mean um like a you know it's it's it's
uh it's very like you know it's like a
swiss army knife i mean i'm in general i
would like to call myself as a data
scientist about 15 years
specifically focusing on cancer research
all right
so
let's go to the topic uh let's go to the
state of modern biomedicine right i mean
it's like a big elephant and we all know
the story that uh
elephant and blind man right some people
that's uh touching their tails and
thinking that's a snake and some of them
touch the
skin and saying it's a wall etcetera
etcetera but nobody gets a big picture
right i mean it's so fragmented and this
fragmentation actually appears
especially when it comes to drug
discovery we have water water everywhere
not a drop to drink and uh data data
everywhere not a drug i think that's one
of the fame um quote that's been um
you know widely used now
but but the key thing is that we all
know that the medicine is very very
fragmented and bifurcated
uh and so we are having a hard time in
reconciling you know what directions to
pursue what are the good targets i mean
people go by single cell rna-seq or i
mean all the things have now
come to the fore good thing is that we
have discovering so much the data is
everywhere
but unfortunately it's all difficult to
put everything together to find a bigger
picture of what's happening in modern
biomedicine
so the key question um as we dive into
the topic is about
nature versus nurture right at the end
of the day we can think of genetics as
something hard coded in our dna
right mutations in deletions etc etc and
then there is a whole phenomenon of
epigenetics where
the methylation and other things can
contribute to
gene expression silencing and uh
and we know that these are this is
another major mainstream mechanism so
people are like
uh some people subscribe to genetics and
some people subscribe to genetics like i
was telling about the elephant and blind
man right i mean uh i have i have seen
people uh saying that okay i am a
geneticist and i i believe in
epigenetics so the key questions is
whether how they interplay right um um
uh one of you i mean whoever have a
strong base in uh studying the dna might
might subscribe to the dna model uh the
basic central dogma and say that
genetics is the
key thing that's driving but but we
really don't know the answer that's the
truth
so in the absence of consensus right in
god we trust all others must bring data
so what does that data tell us right
whether it subscribes to genetics or
whether it says that it's genetic some
genetics we know that it's both but how
much of it right i mean the problem is
that
uh the data now we have a delusion
biology right explosion of data sets now
we have the ngs
they're all bioinformaticians you know
about all these things i don't have to
tell
but then the primary
aspects of the data are mutations copy
numbers when it comes to you know dna of
course gene expression could be
controlled by both by the dna as well as
the rna and
you know there are so many other things
like structural variants and so many
other things that we could study
uh that we are unable to get a consensus
of
what actually is driving right the
tumors
so
so yeah i mean it's like studying the
wings right uh and saying that oh the
aeroplane just runs because of wings and
some people study the engine saying that
oh you know it runs because of engine
right
of course we know that it's both but how
do we study both right without ripping
the plane apart right how do we really
study
the entire structure right the
aerodynamics is not just an outcome of
just a wings or an engine alone right
the aerodynamics is determined by
the flow of the air and it's a process
right the dynamical process it's a
spatio temporal process and not
not a static thing that we could study
by ripping things apart right
so
these are the some of the things that
had uh uh i have been thinking for a
long time
and um that's when i hit upon the
system's biology and i've been thinking
about systems biology i've tried to
watch some videos and everywhere uh when
people talk about systems biology there
is not a
definition of it right people are saying
okay yeah i mean systems biology it's
tough to define right
so the the problem is because um
let's forget the systems biology for a
moment but the whole point of just
studying uh these mechanisms the
biological mechanisms is that the modern
biology is more or less reductionistic
right we we break it apart
we study um hoping that when we study
these parts and try to put together
we will get a
understanding of the entire mechanism
right i mean it is like saying that you
have let's say that we have a bunch of
best cars in the world right i mean one
is good for let's say
a bmw as a best engine and a volvo
probably has the best transmission
and uh
say some other car has a you know best
best
best battery or something like that so
when we are trying to rip everything
separately and trying to organize
something that we can put together we
will not even get an automobile that's
the unfortunate thing we will be able to
rip it apart we will be able to study
but putting it together is not it's
possibly impossible
so so the divide and conquer approach
will not work when studying complex
systems clearly biological systems
um yes and uh especially cancer right
cancer is a very complex and adaptive
it's an evolutionary mechanism the
things constantly the dividing cells
constantly adapt to their environment
and so it becomes uh
it's it's it's an adaptive system and so
it it's it's it's we we will not be able
to put together and study how the
mechanism works in real time right
so when we think about how reductionism
works it is like a relational database
right i mean we break things into tables
and we study each tables right and then
we hope to do some joins
and uh understanding okay so i'm going
to join this table x table x with table
y
uh using some primary key or foreign key
and hoping to understand table x and
table y together right i mean these
joints are made out of inference it is
like a reductionism so you can actually
think about reductionism as a relational
database but but this is not going to
work because putting it together it's
just an interpretation at some point
right it's not going to reveal an answer
by itself so we need an integrative
paradigm which is known as a systems
approach a systems approach is putting
things together and studying it in a
very comprehensive fashion
whether are we ready there at uh whether
or we
do we know how the mechanism works by
integration that's something that's the
biology of the future but
the right approach would be to actually
put things together to see that what
makes sense and what doesn't make sense
uh the systems approach is characterized
by a simple thing the whole is not the
sum of its parts so that that's a
that's the key
sentence that defines systems biology so
the whole the entire picture that you
see is not going to be the sum of the
parts because the interaction between
the parts matters as much as the paths
themselves without the interaction
between the paths the part doesn't make
any sense whatsoever so that is the
entire idea behind systems biology
so how do we uh
then define it right so i was looking
into the
uh the the definitions of systems
biology and i came into this uh
institute for systems biology and uh
they
they have this model where they say that
okay you have the technology and then
new technologies give rise to new data
and the new data give rise to new
software and then out of that doing some
bioinformatics we form new hypothesis
and then the bio
hypothesis will gain rise to new
insights and then new biological
questions this is a cycle life cycle of
a technology computation and biology
that defines uh systems biology but but
this is not true
uh because uh you know it's an
integrative technology that defines
systems biology the integration like i
said the whole is not the sum of the
parts systems biology and complex
adaptive systems
are defined by
uh the integration and when you when you
look at it it's just the technology just
doing some next generation sequencing or
any of these is not going to be or you
know imaging is not going to
define systems biology all we will get
is a bunch of data and of course we can
do bioinformatics with a bunch of data
and then try to answer some questions
but that is not what systems biology is
so um
with this uh we started to and trying to
think about
uh
the goal of the project so i started
thinking about okay what it makes sense
but i'm going to before i go into the
details of
what it how we can really identify
systems biology and how what it has to
do with bioinformatics right
uh start uh let's uh was thinking of
doing a project actually to define uh to
really showcase what it is right so the
goal of the project is creating a
unifying computational framework so it's
a computational framework and we want to
integrate all available patient data
okay so we have we have the tumor
recurrence data the primary data and the
recurrence data
and so we want to integrate all of them
um and then in an unbiased manner for
actionable target validation and
predicting disease outcomes so that's
the in the idea behind the project that
we
initiated at uh
at md anderson cancer center when i
joined i want to start the systems
biology initiative for brain tumors and
the key thing is about integration right
it's it's an integrative technology that
we have to use here
so why
brain tumors
of course it has been my expertise for a
long time
um
for about 10 years i have been involved
in brain tumor research both in
neurosurgery and neuro oncology in
neurosurgery i hold a joint appointment
there so in general i have been studying
brain tumors a lot
and so that was natural for me to do
this
systems
cancer systems biology in glioma so
gluomas or in general the nervous system
neoplasms that uh that that is derived
from epithelial cells
in general the differentiation or
classification is by glial cell types
right i mean usually uh the brain cells
if you take there are neurons there are
astrocytes oligodendrocytes and
epidermocytes
so
in general the gliomas arise from glial
cells and it constitutes about 30
percent of all central nervous system
tumors
and uh in fact in particular if you look
at the brain tumors we have about 70
percent of them
of them are brain tumors or gliomas so
they are divided into two major
categories the low grade glioma and the
high grade glioma
usually the low grade gliomas are grade
2 and 3 which largely consists of
astrocytomas
oligodendroglioma
and then grade 4 which is a high grade
tumor it's usually known as a
glioblastoma it is one of the most
lethal cancers uh people die in about 14
invariably they die in 14 months it's
it's it's a very aggressive cubers and
uh no cure has been i mean or no um
reasonable progress has been made on
gliomas on in glioblastoma for the last
40 50 years despite
there is little progress in terms of
chemotherapy and stuff like that uh
there's not been much progress on that
right
so we not um and then the tcga that the
cancer genome atlas uh started with
understanding of glioblastoma as one of
the key projects in there
and so they we know quite a lot about
molecular biology of clear mass from dna
rna and protein and epigenetic levels
right we know a lot through the
sequencing doing bioinformatics we have
tons and tons of data now uh in pcga on
glioblastoma right
but then uh the problem is that uh
people invariably record right even
though they are given chemotherapy at
some point
uh they they get the tumors again
and so uh
and so uh we really don't know about
what happens how the uh how the relapse
happens and so we start they should
little
know little is known about
tumor primary tumor and recurrence about
progression resistance metastasis and so
many other things so that's why there is
something called glamour glass glioma
analysis consortium called the glass
consortium was formed to understand
glimmer from a recurrence and
a progression perspective and so uh the
glass aims to perform a comprehensive
molecular qualifying uh profiling of uh
maths primary and recon tumors from
thousand five hundred patients
and so this consortium includes
investigators from 14 academic hospitals
and universities md anderson is one of
the core sites
in
for this
glass consortium and uh this glass
consortium uh when i joined i'm a part
of the glass consortium it's led by
investigators in here so i thought the
best case for defining a systems
framework should be to do a glass
use the glass data that has already
profiled tons of tumors both primary and
recurrent tumors and study how the tumor
progression is happening in terms of
both bioinformatics and systems biology
perspective
so what we know about recurrent gliomas
is that the first published study they
analyzed about 222 patients with glioma
so they analyze mutations copy numbers
across a variety of molecular subtypes
of glioma
and there are three major molecular
subtypes of glioma one is idh codal
idh non-codal and idh wild type
so what we know about is that uh the
study also said that okay drivers genes
are initially selected and then they
were retained at recurrence but there is
little evidence of recurrent specific
alterations so most of them happen in
the primary stages
and these are some of the inference that
they have derived the alkaline agents
introduce what is known as a
hypermutator phenotype
and then on employee abnormal number of
chromosomes is frequently detected in
recurrent gliomas
and then the clonal architecture of each
tumor remains similar over time
and no difference in the level of in
from the immune standpoint between
initial and recurrent tumors there is no
difference and these are the inferences
that was derived but the the thing is
that we have to understand these are
done jus just using the basic
bioinformatics they have not
done any data integration across several
types of data to understand glioma
recurrence in a very integrated fashion
right
so that's the key
thing that we wanted to study again is
uh what is missing is that
the key thing is that
they are
what they have uh understood from doing
some rudimentary bioinformatics is that
uh
it's it's it's largely stochastic right
but then we have to integrate gene
expression data we have to integrate
methylation data clinical data think
about the initial uh uh the elephant or
the blindman
slide right i mean we did something
separately we did gene expression
analysis separately we did dna
mutation separately methylation
separately but then we have to put it
together to understand it and how do we
do that right that's the goal of the
project we wanted to create a unifying
again to reiterate uh what we wanted to
accomplish is that creating a unifying
computational framework to integrate all
available patient-centric human
recurrence data
to generate hypothesis in an unbiased
manner for target validation and
predicting disease outcomes so this is
the systems approach not the regular
traditional
individual bioinformatics approach right
so so how do we do such an integration
so here comes the meat of the idea of
how are we going to integrate say very
disparate data let's say that gene
expression data
with mutation data or methylation data
with copy number data how are we going
to even integrate all of these things
right
so that's where what is known as graph
databases coming okay so you might all
have a known graph by graph you might
have meant a pie chart or some kind of a
pictorial representation but that is not
what a graph is from a mathematical
standpoint um it's a it's a name for a
network right uh it consists of nodes
and edges right
so in traditional databases you have
these uh separate tables and we are
trying to infer things together right so
you have mutations let's say you have a
copy number table and a methylation
table and you join them try to do some
um
understanding based on the bio the
mutations copy number and methylations
would be done so based on some
bioinformatics right i mean
there are mutation callers
or some pipeline git k pipeline and so
many other things right but then there
is uh
but then there is no explicit
relationships that are embedded into
these tables and so you have to infer
these things separately right but graph
databases the relationships are defined
right think about facebook think about
amazon think about all these things
right i mean how do they even work for
instance amazon you buy a product and
immediately says that okay this product
uh also uh what do you mean uh when you
buy this product people who bought this
product also had brought another product
so how do how do they infer that
in real time right people there is no
person sitting there and trying to
analyze your product and then
try to match up with other people's
product who also purchase the product
right i mean these relationships are
already embedded in here and so it's
just a matter of querying right there so
there is a system already in place that
has this relationships defined
and so it immediately points out to the
product people who bought this also
bought this it's an association right
those associations are already mapped
same with things happens with facebook
right a friend of a friend friend is a
relationship between two people right so
when you have is a friend off can be
embedded so that it can be naturally
rendered in real time and similarly
happens with twitter and also many new
technologies are just based on these
kinds of graphic graph databases
so
so the graph architecture the
integration is natural um
and it's an unbiased analysis becomes
very very uh you know
easy right
so all you need to do is define the
relationships and uh and so we can write
appropriate queries to answer that right
so is this idea new not really if you
think about uh this idea it's already
been one of the papers that was actually
a very
good paper in fact that was
key for me
to develop this is that uh they have
already done this in what is known as a
colorectal cancer they had these
mutations and that they have this
relationships defined
and then um they have tried to integrate
all these together using the graph
databases right and so the problem with
their model is that
they have to create additional
relationship for new data let's say that
you're introducing image data so they
have to introduce new
you know relationship type and also uh
it results in restricted survival
analysis we will go over that a little
bit later
so uh the key so then there are problems
with the existing approach uh the key
attributes of the system that it should
be integrative you have to put in all
data that you can find and it has to be
unbiased
uh as well as uh it has to be absolute
in time uh so these are the
characteristics of the system that we
have to develop and so uh
so that i was thinking about it and the
idea is very simple so you have two
molecular events and you connect them
saying that if there are patients who
undergo those events
then that forms a relationship so the
patients are the relationships in our
model right so in our database there is
this basic representation there are
these molecular events
and you connect them if they are
if there are more than one patient who
undergoes those two molecular events
right
so with that we built this graph
database where we were able to integrate
copy numbers where we were able to
integrate methylation mutation
expression
and if you are having imaging we can
integrate whatever data that you can get
we can actually put them in this
database so this is in this database we
call it as graph engine for systems
medicine or otherwise genome in uh
database they have an intel in this
database it's all it's an integrative
database
and so we would be able to uh query
anything that we want right um
so there are 370 patients in this
database so far about 11k nodes and 16
million relationships and this is the
venn diagram of how the distribution of
the data looks like
so why bioinformatics critical now that
comes to the critical question for this
right so like i said garbage in uh
garbage out
right i mean it depends on how you
define the system and it's it's very
important when you're constructing such
a systems biology approach
it's it makes sense that we have to make
sure that we really put in all the
things that are important right so we
make sure there is a good bioinformatics
uh that is built uh in in in in
developing the system so for instance uh
identifying mutations right we identify
key driver mutations so there is a
pipeline already
we have alignment and a gatk variant
calling and then we do the driver
passenger analysis and do the mutation
uh driver passenger mutations and then
we upload it into the database so it's
important otherwise it's all garbage
there's going to be millions and
millions of data points so this is where
the bioinformatics is critical before
it's it's the next the whole systems
approach is uh the downstream of
bioinformatics that's critical to
understand and there is secondly
there is this patience there is another
filter in there it's determined by the
number of patients who undergo the
molecular events and also we have a
robust statistics and connected events
as another filter and then we do a
random walk and survival correlation so
these graph databases have a survival
correlation so like i said right two
events are connected by patients so a
patient a trajectory a could be
different from patient trajectory b
could be different from patient
relativity c so they will have different
types of survival
so in general we could enumerate all
type of paths that's going to give
different survival but that's going to
be extremely hard problem it's an mp
complete problem in computer science so
we will not be able to do that so what
we do is that we simulate a random walk
random walk is like
how many you know it's just a tossing
the coin so if if it's like no say there
are six parts in here if you throw die
and if it says five you take part number
five etc etc so in general we would be
able to simulate a random walk
and then do the survival correlation so
for instance in this one of the walks in
here we have the path number 51 and path
number 54 right they show the survival
difference between the patients and what
you see is a bunch of different
biomarkers or
genes that's a combination right it's
not just a combination of me it's just
as mutations or copy numbers it's a
combination of this that gives the
difference in survival so in this way we
would be able to determine the survival
of patients
and this is another random work
simulation too so we have these two
parts which show completely different
survival times
uh this is random walk three for another
specific type of glioma where we see the
survival difference between the patients
for path number 16 patients who take
that path and patients who don't take
that path
so the power of this approach we have
identified several functionally
important genes for conducting
biological experiments so for instance
there is a recent study that says that
glutamate synaptic signaling is
important deal in signaling so we have
identified all of these things
uh in general right this provides a
strong framework for systems biology
paradigm in medicine um it's it's
patient driven then patient property is
given it's uh truly unbiased and
integrative it's not subject to time as
long as there are patients we are going
to have this
framework and it's correlating with
survival combining multiple parker's has
not been attempted so um
so with that uh i would like to
acknowledge
the and the support i have got the
patients and their families my student
phd students he has been actively
developing the database
uh dr hughes puduvali and then dr lang a
neurosurgery chair and neuro oncology
chair they provided an unwavering
support of course
my senior vice president and cto of md
anderson um he used he he was like
totally in sync with these ideas and
helped me helped us
in providing all the support in here
moonshot gave us the funding brain tumor
center gave the resources
of course the database supported md
anderson and the id staff we were
available anytime that we wanted to go
and have some problems and of course
this was done on neo4j neo4j team rob
martin fannie and greg shelley they were
critical in providing the neo4j for us
in developing this system
so with that uh i would like to end my
talk um and uh open the floor for
questions
very good thank you thank you doctor uh
we do have several questions if you want
to go ahead and pull your uh screen off
we can just see you in instead
oh so one of the questions is yeah we'll
even make you uh get me off the bottom
here we don't well yeah we there we go
so
is the database you're describing be
being used by clinicians right now
yes there have been uh utilized by
clinicians uh we are testing out
uh certain biomarkers that were derived
out of this database yes
okay fascinating
so how important is it for a clinician
to be aware of the data analysis methods
to use it properly
uh well uh we won't expect too much uh
inside i mean uh for clinicians to
understand the database and the queries
which we will handle
uh all i think uh now what we would
expect for the clinicians to know is
that we can provide some actionable
targets and uh for them if they
understand a little bit of biology to
see that what makes sense and what
doesn't make sense for them to conduct
some biological experiments i think that
would be fantastic
okay it's probably really important to
know where and how the data was
accumulated so they can use it properly
is that right
yes of course yeah yeah i mean yeah so
we have to develop systems like systems
like this for each and disease types
you
do you see any challenges that need to
be addressed to integrate data when it
does not come from the exact same
patient but rather different individuals
oh yeah i mean this database is about
different individuals right it's about
population so it's not just one patient
we have about 370 patients in our
database
uh data that we are integrating so yeah
any type of data any type of patients we
should be able to integrate this
database using this approach well thank
you thank you for your remarkable work
that you're doing with cancer i i loved
all the metaphors throughout the the
elephant and all that that's that's
pretty good stuff
we're gonna